criticizing the slow pace of
counter-offensive equals to spitting
into the face of Ukrainian soldier who
sacrifices his life every day moving
forward and liberating one kilometer of
Ukrainian soil after another I would
recommend all critics to shut up come to
Ukraine and try to liberate one square
centimeter by themselves thank you
the war is Raging artillery ammunition
we hope that things will begin to to
work smoothly with the initiative that
you adopted armored vehicles tanks and
for those who cannot provide military
you know lethal equipment please
consider medevox which are
armored ambulances to evacuate wounded
soldiers from from the battlefield this
is this is very high high demand
followers